sur ces photos publiées par les
autorités de transnistrie deux antennes
qui relayait les fréquences
radiophoniques russe mise hors service
des dégâts causés par une série
d'explosions qui a eu lieu ce mardi
matin dans ce territoire moldave
frontalier de l'ukraine est soutenue par
des séparatistes russe lundi déjà les
autorités de transnistrie affirmait que
le ministère de la sécurité publique
avait été la cible d'une attaque au
lance grenades
aucune victime n'est à déplorer mais
maya sens d'où la présidence moldave a
réuni son conseil de sécurité nationale
analyser les datas
notre analyse montre qu'il y à des
tensions entre plusieurs forces à
l'intérieur de la région qui ont intérêt
à déstabiliser la situation nous devons
rester calmes et nous informer avec des
sources vérifiées
le chef de la région transnistrie lui
pointe du doigt l'ukraine
république autoproclamée à majorité
russophone
la transnistrie a fait sécession de la
moldavie dans la foulée de
l'effondrement de l'union soviétique
la moldavie gouverné depuis 2020 par une
pro européenne redoutent d'être la
prochaine cible de moscou une inquiétude
qui s'est accentué la semaine dernière
après les déclarations d'un commandant
de l'armée russe le contrôle du sud de
l'ukraine c'est également un couloir
vers la transnistrie où on observe
également des cadeaux pression de la
population russophone
des propos qui ont fait réagir h is in
an ces déclarations ne sont pas fondées
et sont contradictoires avec le soutien
de la russie à la souveraineté et à
l'intégrité territoriale de notre pays
au moins 1500 soldats russes sont
présents en transnistrie depuis 1995